I remember a couple years ago you and I
are on the phone and I said Ron you know
what would we say if somebody asked us
for the five things that family should
do to really be effective in supporting
their children's development and by
golly you went off and took that
question and ran with it so could you
talk a little bit about that
intervention yeah and I just want to put
it in context a little bit for the
achievement gap initiative we're trying
to do work that hits on the parenting
school and peer groups as supported by
the business community in the larger
community and so trying to have work
going on in each of those circles and so
what we're talking about here are the
things have to do with parenting and
families and we've distilled from the
research literature five principles you
might call them of early childhood
parenting and caregiving Boston basics
are what we call five fun and simple
things that any parent can do beginning
at birth and they are to maximize love
and manage stress to talk sing in point
to count group and compare to explore
through movement and to read and discuss
and our intention is to saturate it
first one neighborhood in Boston then
the rest of the city and after that
we'll have a kit that people who people
anywhere can use the nugget for me that
affected what our emphasis is with what
now we call in the Boston basics was
probably four or five years ago looking
at the early childhood longitudinal
survey and seeing that racial and
socio-economic differences are not very
apparent around the first birthday but
they're stark by the second birthday
right if we know that then how can we
not do something about it I mean the
gaps that were interested in are
starting to open up so early